this year's Nobel Prize in Physics is
awarded for scientific work that has
built the foundation to our modern
information society the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences has decided to award
the 2009 new Nobel Prize in Physics with
1/2 - Charles Cao firmly working at
standard telly
telecommunications laboratory in Harlow
United Kingdom and at the Chinese
University of Hong Kong and the Academy
citation runs for groundbreaking
achievements concerning the transmission
of light in fibers for optical
communication and the other half of the
prize is awarded jointly to build a boil
and George Smith both of them firmly
working at the Bell Laboratories Murray
Hills New Jersey USA and they shared
their half of the price for the
invention of an imaging simha conductor
circuit the CCD sensor
you